-How are you?
-I'm -- I'm great.
I, uh --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
-Very happy you're here.
-I just met Fred Armisen..
-Yeah.
-...backstage
before the show started.
And always been
a huge fan of his,
including a cover that he di
of The Clash's cover,
"Police on my Back,"
which just blew my mind
when I saw on YouTube.
So, honored to be with you
Fred, yeah.
-Thank you.
-Yeah, and this is a real thin
about you that you are
a great lover of punk rock
You were, in the '90s,
a punk rocker.
Fair to say?
-I'd like to think
somewhere inside I still am.
-Yeah.
-Seth, yeah.
-Do you think the punk rocke
that is still inside you
is surprised that you,
the outside you,
is running for president?
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe just a little bit,
but I'll tell you,
this campaign, at its best
has a do-it-yourself
ethic and spirit.
We don't take a dime
from a single
political action committee
or corporation
or special interest or lobbyist.
It's all people, all the time,
driving from one town
to the next, showing up,
telling our story but listenin
to the stories of others,
which was kind of like touring
in a punk rock band
in the 1990s --
[ Laughter ]
A little bit.
-Yeah.
Probably a nicer car situation
-Yes, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
We were touring in a --
We called it the Lumber Wagon.
It was a station wagon
with four guys, our amps,
the drum kit, and maybe on
change of clothes per person
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then on the road
for the entire summer.
But one of the best ways
to spend that part of our lives,
and it's still with me.
It's still with me.
-That's fantastic.
I also want to ask,
you were in Brooklyn last nigh
doing an event.
You used to live in Brooklyn
-Yeah.
-Is this a true story that you
had a trampoline on your roo
that you got from Busta Rhymes
-So --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers ]
-And now, again, I --
By the way, I get that thi
is a thing that
a lot of candidates have.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
The answer is "yes."
So, a roommate of ours,
it was either Dylan or Stephan
was working on the set
of a Busta Rhymes video.
-Uh-huh.
-Somehow came home
with a trampoline
and then managed to assemble i
on the roof of the buildin
that we were living in
on Wallabout Street
in Williamsburg in 1996.
And it doesn't sound like
the safest thing in the world,
but here we were,
jumping on a trampoline
on the top of a building.
Everyone survived.
-I'm sure --
By the way, I'm sure
Busta Rhymes checked it
to make sure it was safe.
I mean...
-Totally, yeah.
-If you're gonna get one
that you can trust for safety,
that's it.
-Busta Rhymes, every time.
-I want to ask,
'cause we're coming up
next week,
another round of these debates
10 candidates,
two different nights.
And it does seem like
one of the hardest parts
is sort of differentiating
yourself from other candidates
with whom you share a lot.
Obviously.
You ran against Ted Cruz
in a Senate campaign.
Do you ever miss how easy it was
to be different from Ted Cruz?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Where is Ted Cruz
when you need him?
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
-Very rarely uttered,
and yet here we are.
Yeah.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-True.
It's true.
You know, what was so grea
about that campaign in Texas
beyond getting a chance
to run against Ted Cruz,
was running in a state tha
had been taken for granted
Really written off.
Ranked 50th in voter turnout
And in addition
to getting to debate him,
we went to every single one of
the 254 counties in that state
So, no matter how big or blue,
we showed up
because we didn't want
to take you for granted.
No matter how small or red o
rural, we showed up there, too
because we didn't want
to write you off.
Some places had voted
for Donald Trump 96%
in the 2016 election.
One place, Archer County,
that we went to,
no candidate from Senate
from either party
had shown up in 70 years
when LBJ dropped out of the sk
in a helicopter in 1948,
landed on
the courthouse grounds,
and walked over
to the American Legion Hall.
It had been that long
since anyone
had shown up to listen to them
So that was
what was so exciting.
And at the end of the day,
we turned out in record numbers.
Won more votes
than any Democrat had
in the history
of the state of Texas.
So it was really
an extraordinary election.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And you won a lot of --
I think --
I think it was almost
about a half a million votes
of people that voted
for Greg Abbott, a Republican...
-That's right.
-...who also voted for you
So, this is, I think,
one of the reasons why
there was enthusiasm
for the idea of you runnin
is maybe you can connect peopl
who don't agree usually
with a Democratic candidate.
Obviously, there's a scalability
question with the United State
versus -- I mean, again,
don't get me wrong,
Texas is pretty impressive
as far as size,
but is that your plan here
is just to sort of get wheel
down everywhere you can?
-Absolutely.
That's the consistent theme,
from being on the road with th
guys in the band 25 years ag
to being on the road
across 254 counties of Texas
to this weekend being at
The Diving Elk,
a great bar in Sioux City,
and taking questions from people
who were there,
introducing myself,
and then going to Sioux Center
which is one of the most,
if not the most,
conservative places
in the state of Iowa
and not writing anybody of
and not asking,
"Who did you vote for
for President last time?
What party do you belong to?
Who do you pray to,
or who do you love?"
Non importa.
I do not care.
Just tell me what's importan
to you right now.
We're Americans first
before we're anything else
And I got to tell you,
in addition to showing up
with the courage
of our convictions
and talking about what we want
to see for America,
I'm learning so much
by listening to people
about what's important to them
in their lives.
And they never ask
about polling.
They never ask about
fundraising.
They don't care
about the horse race.
They want to know
how they're gonna afford
prescription medication
or how we're gonna get
mental healthcare not as
a function of luck or fortun
but as a human right that ever
single American can depend on.
And I think that's something
that unites us
across the differences that we
have in this country right now
[ Cheers and applause ]